on continue de parler de ces
manifestations à travers la france avec
nos deux invités christophe longo
président du collectif des discothèques
paca corse et laurent alexandre et
l'essayiste et chirurgie bonsoir
messieurs merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france alors nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre le passé
ni terre et la vaccination obligatoire
deux jours après la validation du projet
de loi par le conseil constitutionnel
la mobilisation se poursuit elle ne
semble pas être entendus ni par le
gouvernement ni par le conseil
constitutionnel est ce que c'est encore
utile de continuer à se mobiliser pour
des mesures qui vont malgré tout être
appliquée ça sera dans deux jours
maintenant
laurent alexandre le taux de vaccination
a beaucoup beaucoup augmenté en france
et la france bat est leader du monde
occidental en pourcentage de mon nous
vacciner il y avait un essoufflement
important est aujourd'hui une reprise
qui est rapide donc on peut penser qu'il
va y avoir un effet positif de cette
vaccination quasi obligatoire et je
pense que les français y verront plutôt
quelque chose de positif car il est
probable qu'on va davantage contrôler la
quatrième vague en france avec un taux
de vaccination très élevé que dans
d'autres pays où il risque d'y avoir un
sursaut des contaminations plus élevé
donc je pense que c'est une phase
temporaire
7 ces manifestations agrège des gens
extrêmement hétérogène on à l'extrême
extrême droite avec dupont aignan
philippot a puisque le rassemblement
national n'a pas pris parti tellement
contre la vaccination obligatoire
on a les complotistes on a une partie de
l'extrême droite catholique notamment
une partie des anti mariage gay est très
actif
les anti vaccins traditionnels la
mouvance de serge nader même si serge
nader lui même et est mort des suites du
coc vides beaucoup de gilets jaunes donc
cela agrège des gens extrêmement
hétérogène je ne crois pas que ça puisse
faire un mouvement durable parce qu'il
ya quand même une grosse partie des
français qui sont en train de se faire
vacciner et qui vont adhérer au passage
à lutter de manière à ce qu'on puisse
tout ré ouvrir car la plus grosse
probabilité aujourd'hui
si on atteint 85% de vaccination c'est
qu'on puisse tout ré ouvrir à partir
d'octobre
y compris les discothèques et qu'on
supprime assez rapidement le pass
sanitaire parce qu'on va arriver à
l'immunité collective rapidement et la
france sera probablement le pays au
monde où l'immunité collective arrivera
en premier
sauf grand malheur c'est à dire
l'arrivée d'un nouveau variant qui lui
seraient résistant aux au vaccin mais
pour l'instant on n'a pas de variants
résistant au vaccin mais y en a un le
variant colombien je ne sais pas si vous
avez entendu parler de ces sept
personnes qui ont perdu la vie alors
qu'elles étaient vaccinés c'était en
belgique
ça reste ça reste marginal pour
l'instant on peut paniquer les gens en
prenant tout l'alphabet grec mais pour
l'instant on n'est pas très très très
inquiet sur le var yolanda alors
christophe longo vous êtes président du
collectif des discothèques paca corse
comment vous allez vous organiser avec
fait pas sanitaire beh nous il faut
savoir qu'on est ouvert depuis le 9
juillet face à lithaire alors je me
demande with it et les manifestants car
nous l'imposé parce que apparemment
sachant que tout le monde à partir de
maintenant mais pour les discothèques
sachant que les personnes qui nous
imposent autres solitaires donc déjà la
première question on n'est pas des sous
chefs d'entreprise ou des sociétés je
comprends pas trop que certaines
personnes jusqu'à présent
et deuxièmement si la ce pour moi ça
n'engage que moi c'est la seule solution
pour qu'on puisse les oublie nos
établissements en toute sécurité
il faut pas se faire d'illusions car moi
je croise les gens manifester les uns
sur les autres sans aucun masque qui
portent pas le masque je trouve ça
irresponsable de leur part en pleine
pandémie
donc je pense que maintenant il est très
peu de clusters dans les discothèques
depuis disons qu'on a rouvert avec le
pass annie terre par contre je prends le
cas d'aix en provence il ya but
restaurants qui ont été fermées pour
cause de clusters donc je pense qu'il
est indispensable
c'est sûr que ça va gêner sur l'activité
je suis le premier gène et il faut
savoir que à l'heure actuelle je suis à
50 % de mon chiffre d'affaires que je
fais d'habitude mais je pense que c'est
la seule solution pour qu'on puisse
travailler en toute sécurité parce que à
travers le passé ni tendu parce qu'on a
un devoir citoyen et nos responsabilités
à travers nous que les gens ne tombent
pas malades mais vous comprenez
christophe longo que certains
s'inquiètent de cette vaccination
certains estiment qu'il n'y a pas assez
de recul pour sur ses vaccins qui ont
été créés très rapidement je peux le
comprendre et le bats et ses personnels
aussi je peux le comprendre
par contre on n'a pas le droit de
contaminer les autres non plus si on
veut pas se faire vacciner a bel et bien
on en peut pas sortir c'est malheureux
mais on n'a pas le droit de condamner
les autres non plus c'est la solution
moi je suis pas médecin je suis pas
scientifique
je pense qu'il arrive un moment où pour
faire confiance à nos pouvoirs publics
et c'est la seule solution qui semble
viable pour pour les chefs d'entreprise
que nous sommes donc malgré que ce soit
de trois contraintes attention je vous
dis pas que c'est facile ou bien le
contraire mais il comprend une vie
normale et on reprendra une vie de plus
en plus normal autour rapidement
possible par sept par cette manière là
demain ça n'engage que moi ce que je
pense moi le romarin je sais que j'avais
des collègues qui étaient contre le
passe à lithaire également et il faut
savoir qu'on est que que un quart des
établissements à avoir le mauvais
rihanna qui l'auront fusillade
laurent alexandre la vaccination c'est
vraiment la solution numéro un numéro un
pour lutter contre la propagation du
commis 19 on a des données qui nous
arrivent de l'étranger qui nous disent
qu on peut tout de même transmettre ce
virus malgré le fait qu'on soit vaccinée
alors d'abord dire qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul et expertises sur
le vaccin c'est franchement pas
raisonnable on approche 4 milliards
d'injection des vaccins jamais on n'a eu
autant de reculs autant d' expertise sur
un nouveau médicament ou sur un nouveau
vaccin
donc on a une connaissance de ce vaccin
et de ses effets secondaires qui sont
extrêmement faibles
il ya un petit peu d'effets secondaires
avec l'astra zeneca et de john seine
vous savez bien mais on est en train
d'arrêter de les prescrits en france et
en revanche avec le moderna et le riser
il n'y a quasiment aucun effet
secondaire moi j'ai fait vacciner toute
ma famille ma femme est vaccinée tous
mes enfants y compris mineurs sont
vaccinés je n'ai pas eu le moindre doute
ni en tant que médecin ni en tant que
citoyen ni en tant que père de famille a
donc on a un très bon recul sur les
sur sur les vaccins alors on a vu parmi
les manifestants qui ont été interrogés
par vos journalistes des gens qui disent
ah mais on a des traitements qui coûte
rien on a des traitements très efficaces
mais ça ça n'est pas vrai hélas s'il
hydroxy chloroquine six protocoles raul
tu marchais si les verts mais qd il
marchait ce serait formidable mais ça
n'est pas le cas toutes les études
sérieuses montrent que le protocole raul
ne marche pas montre que lee
d'hermétique ne marche pas donc c'est ça
le problème c'est que parmi les
manifestants beaucoup sont persuadés
qu'il y à des traitements médicamenteux
efficace or ça n'est pas le cas hélas il
n'y a aucun traitement qui fonctionne et
si les traitements existait vous
imaginez bien être le corps médical les
prescrirait nous serions tous tous pour
malheureusement cela ne marche pas il
n'y a plus aucun pays sérieux développé
avec un système de santé moderne qui
prescrit hydroxy chloroquine alors
quelques pays du tiers-monde prescrivent
de l'hydroxyde plan qui pour des raisons
politiques parce que les politiciens
veulent faire croire qu'ils font quelque
chose mais ce n'est pas pour des raisons
d'efficacité médicale ce n'est pas pour
rendre service à la population
c'est pour cacher le fait qu'il n'ya pas
d'oxygène qu'il n'y a pas de réanimation
ce sont donc des manoeuvres
politiciennes et pas des non pas des
protocoles médicamenteux donc
malheureusement on n'a pas de traitement
et s'il y en avait et j'en serai
vraiment chanter mais on en n'a pas il
n'ya pas qu'hydro xi chloroquine et puis
l'ivermectine qui ont échoué il ya
d'autres médicaments antiviraux qui
était en cours de développement ces
derniers mois et qui malheureusement ou
échoués dans les études
donc pour l'instant on a zéro molécules
on n'a que deux façons de traiter ces
vagues pour préserver notamment nos
aînés les personnes âgées c'est soit l'
isolement
soit le vaccin moi personnellement je
préfère aller au restaurant vacciner
plutôt que de rester sans restaurant
sans vaccin surtout quand on a des
vaccins avec aussi peu d'effets
secondaires que le modern art et le
kaiser alors christophe longo est
certains manifestants dénoncent à un
apartheid en évoquant ce pass sanitaire
vous pensez qu'on est dans l'exagération
oui on est à l'heure
comment cela dit j'ai ration totale et
c'est plus de la récupération politique
qu'autre chose donc est-ce que la
solution est ce qu'ils ont une solution
à proposer
pour pas que si on n'utilise pas
sanitaires pour pas que nos
établissements vont faire les
restaurants et des bars et des
discothèques
est-ce qu'ils ont des solutions ces
gens-là proposés c'est ça la question
qu'il faut se poser la seule solution
c'est la vaccination et le pas salutaire
il faut il faut être raisonnable il faut
être il faut être et avoir
il faut le faire donc c'est l'éditeur ou
le quatrième confinement à l'art si vous
qu'on voit là exactement c'est ou le
pass and it et ont carrément un
confinement
quand je pense que si on veut retrouver
une vie normale le plus rapidement
possible ça passe par le passage du ter
la vaccination
ça n'engage que moi c'est mon avis
laurent alexandre il faut passer par là
or cette période
oui oui on va pas on va parvenir les
dernières où les restaurants ont été
fermées en belgique et en france sept
mois et demi
y'en a ras-le-bol on va pas passer un
hiver de plus 100 sports d'hiver sont
remontées mécaniques sens qui sans
loisirs
il faut arrêter maintenant il faut
reprendre une vie normale alors hélas
avec le le variant delta qui est plus
contagieux que les variants viraux
initiaux qui ont eu pour qu'on soit
tranquilles et condé immunité collective
il faut malheureusement 80 85 % de la
population vaccinée
alors qu'avec le premier variant 60%
suffisait donc il faut vacciner plus que
ce qu'on a fait c'est pour ça que
l'obligation vaccinale est aujourd'hui
malheureusement obligatoire mais je suis
vraiment plutôt confiant je suis étonné
de l'accélération de la vaccination
on est aujourd'hui à 0 5% de la
population française qui chaque jour va
faire sa première injection
donc on va pas arriver dans une zone de
protection en avril qui est en septembre
pardon qui est vraiment rassurante
je pense j'espère qu'on va sortir du
tunnel et qu'on va avoir la bonne
surprise de pouvoir supprimer le pass
sanitaire dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois
dès lors qu'on aura une immunité
collective à partir de 80 85 % de la
population française ayant eu les deux
injections afin dupas sanitaire le 15
novembre indigne
gouvernement si la situation sanitaire
le père mais merci messieurs d'avoir
répondu à nos questions alors laurent
alexandrins chapelle vous êtes essayiste
et chirurgiens merci à vous également
christophe longo président du collectif
des discothèques paca corse merci merci
messieurs